billionaire bill gates says bars and
restaurants will have to close
until deep into the next year as he
claims the worst of the pandemic is yet
to come
sadly the next four to six months could
be the worst of the epidemic
bars and restaurants in most of the
country will be closed as we go into
this wave and i think
sadly that's appropriate former chief
economist for the international trade
commission
peter maurici joins us live peter you
know i like getting you fired up that
word obscene
that you called bill gates comments why
do you call him obscene
well he said it was good for capitalism
and it certainly isn't these people
are not folks that build homes on the
shore knowing a hurricane would
eventually come and then are
then a screaming that they're being told
to evacuate these these folks are like
folks who
built a restaurant in iowa and a meteor
hit them so to say it's good for
capitalism is just
silly uh i don't know that we need the
level of closures we're having we
certainly need them in places or to
restrict usage
but to say we should virtually shut
everybody down i mean
has any seen the carnage this has cost i
guess he's just a little too insulated
like the rest of the silicon valley from
the pains and aches of ordinary
americans
isn't this theme being repeated over and
over sort of a tone deafness from people
who aren't billionaires who don't have a
steady paycheck coming in
i.e you know the people like governors
and
legislators who do have that paycheck
closing down the people who don't
yeah it just seems like this pattern is
repeating itself throughout the last
nine months
you know and we focus on restaurant
workers and public-facing workers as we
should because they're some of the most
vulnerable with the incomes they have
but let's remember a hundred thousand
small businesses have closed
they have accountants and lawyers and so
forth that next year won't have clients
and they're laying people off
and on it goes also while we're locked
down and working in satellite format
at work at home format we can keep
things going but the normal processes of
hiring are not proceeding the number of
jobs created or is declining
and we will return to the same level of
activity by
20 20 22 but we will have lost two years
of growth which means about
oh three million jobs or so that that's
that's that's what's obscene
and if you weren't upset with gates by
now listen to this he's
attacking the america first policy
obviously the trump administration
policy saying
we the united states should prioritize
vaccines in third
world countries i look at this peter and
say isn't this like being on a plane
where you need to put on your mask first
before putting on somebody else's in
other words
don't we need to help ourselves before
we can help others
well the hard reality is the vaccines
that we have coming up present
can't really be distributed to poor
areas in the third world very
effectively because of the refrigeration
required and the protocol of double
doses
uh again you know he likes to fly off
but he he just is out of touch it's
it's an unfortunate when very young men
and women earn billions of dollars i
mean it's great that they create this
wealth
but then they go off and live on a
mountaintop and say gee look at all
those people scaring around
they shouldn't run around so much the
exercise is bad for them they'll die
young that way
come up here and clip your coupons and
live on your savings and
and live and live the spiritual life i
mean he thinks he's heading some sort of
secular religion
this is absurd to think that americans
should die
after developing the vaccine uh it's
just absurd
tell me he should pick out the the
hundred million americans that should
die because of his philanthropy
philanthropic prescriptions it seems
like that mountain you describe as
particularly tall
there in silicon valley and in
washington state and lots of
clouds so we can't see peter maurici we
always appreciate your time thanks sir
take care carly